give the ladies some advice maybe goals
that women should look out for by the
time they're 30 and by the time they're
40 in your experience
all right well women are a different
conversation my friends
I need a different show for this one
yeah
um again so I mean if I was giving
advice to my daughter it would be to
preserve her femininity and her beauty
men are success objects they always have
been to women and women are Beauty slash
sex doctors to men they always have been
to men so now that doesn't really comply
with the narrative with society today
because women have been told for decades
now you don't need no man a woman needs
a man like a fish needs a bicycle blah
blah blah climb the corporate ladder get
degrees frame them in Mahogany with
little letters after your name and go
chase excellence and then by the time
they get to 40 they're wondering where
all the good guys are and their eggs are
drying up and they're starting to freak
out some it even happens by the time
they're getting close to 30 you know for
being honest so
I think women sort of
I mean I hate to say it but they don't
pay much attention to this stuff because
women kind of have a free ride because
when you're young and you're beautiful
everybody gives you attention even when
you're older there's lots of 30 40 50
year old women today that get loads of
attention from guys if they're even half
you know half decent looking
um so they don't need to contemplate
these things I mean most of the time
when women ask me this question it's
because they're Pastor Prime in their
late 30s early 40s sometimes 50s and
they're asking for help and it's like I
don't have a time machine what we need
to do is put you in a time machine back
to when you're 20 and talk about not
running through 100 guys not you know
partying not wasting your youth uh
getting different degrees climbing the
corporate ladder if your goal was to
have a family
um you know for some women they might
just say never want to have a family I'm
not fertile I'm never going to be
fertile so I just want to chase
Excellence so you kind of you know sort
of the same sort of conversation that
you know we're talking about with guys
they have to get serious about the path
around I don't think men or women
take much time or consideration planning
their life path yeah I think such a
powerful point because
you know I'm at the phase of my life
where I know a lot of women in their
late 30s early 40s that I've grown up
with right and some of these women were
the hottest girls in school and now
they're single right and I'm also at the
phase of my life where I still hang out
with women in their 20s right just kind
of out there and yeah
living in South Beach going to nightlife
20 year olds you don't want this life
Richard I'm telling you this ain't for
the weekend your head and shame exactly
so you know you know there's this whole
debate these days of like are men and
women the same are we different are we
equal are we not I I I don't think
there's any doubt that men and women men
and women are quote unquote equal but I
will say they we are definitely
different and one of the most poignant
examples of that is what I think I think
is that a a man can afford the luxury of
bsing his way through his twenties you
know makes a mistake sleep with the
wrong girl date with the wrong girl take
the wrong job this that the other next
thing you know you're 27 you're 28
you're 32 you still have time to recover
a woman does not have that luxury
biologically speaking a woman who messes
around with a long wrong relationship
wrong job wrong career they go to school
next thing you know they're 27 they're
29 they're 33. next thing you know
they're 35 they can't necessarily have
babies anymore and everything whether
it's a man or a woman it comes it comes
down to who do you want to be and I
think that 80 of men and women this is
my opinion no stats to back this up I
think that the majority of men and women
do want to have someone in their life
and do you want to have kids whether
that's getting married under the
government or not I think that most men
and women do want to have someone in
their life and especially women want to
have kids so to your point you can't go
back into a time machine when you're 34
when you're 37 you're 42
all you can do is learn from people that
are older than you and learn from their
mistakes so whether it's a podcast like
this or whether it's asking a woman you
know who's 40 years old be like are you
happy with your life you know women
really have to kind of make these
decisions a lot sooner than men and
value who they're dating a lot sooner
than what men are doing like you're
let's just say in your 40s late late 40s
good looking man what experience have
you seen with women in their 40s saying
Richard I wish I would have met you 10
years ago five years ago I wish I would
have heard this before what experience
do you have from women in that regard
well you know Cyndi Lauper covered it
Girls Just Want to Have Fun
you know they've spent their 20s and
they're sometimes even a good part of
their 30s just having fun yeah and they
don't you know they don't think about
these consequences and why would they
you know they've been told to go have
fun they've told you know they've been
told to be promiscuous they've been told
to behave like men they've been told to
get degrees in climb corporate ladders
they've been told to put off having a
family they've been told freezer eggs
they've been told we've got science that
can fix all of this right so why
wouldn't they just go and have fun right
yeah it's by the way this strikes a
major chord with me These Girls Just
Want to Have Fun because my whole thing
is you're familiar with the kiss
principle keep it simple stupid just
break down things that and just simplify
them so I've simplified what I call the
circle of life and I should probably do
a visualization of this but in my
opinion there's four phases of life
right hear me out so at the top of the
list is guys want girls men just want
women
girls step two girls Girls Just Want to
Have Fun right like you just said Cindy
Lauper Girls Just Want to Have Fun you
go to any club Cyndi Lauper comes on
girl stop what they're doing congregate
dance Girls Just Wanna Have we've all
seen it before we've all lived out loud
now here's the funny thing about fun fun
costs of money this is number three
phone costs money whether it's a date
whether it's a trip whether it's a
vacation hell whether it's a picnic you
still need to bring things to the picnic
okay you got to put [__] in the picnic
basket okay so fun costs money and this
leads me to number four men men need to
make money men need to make money so
they can afford the fun now you might
ask yourself how does this become the
circle of life well because at the other
end of the circle why do men need to
make money because we go back to number
one
because guys just want girls and they're
they're circle at the of life right
there because guys want Girls Girls Just
Want fun fun costs money men didn't make
money because guys want girls so your
answer couldn't be more appropriate let
me transition every single atom out of
every single guy that I know that's in
their 50s or 60s that's a
multi-billionaire you know they've got
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
dollars they all say the same thing I
wish I had more of this money when I was
younger again this is why I'm telling
guys Chase Excellence not women aim to
be a millionaire by the time you're 30
right what's the famous quote get as
close as you can the famous quote what
is it youth is wasted on the young what
is that yeah it is but isn't there real
quick there's also like a little bit of
I would say bad to that because I feel
like if you give men or they have access
to money at such a young age there is
also a higher chance that they waste it
on things like that yeah you know
because a lot of time like those women
who just want to have fun they're not
not really long-term women so I think
essentially even though men are making
money maybe a little bit later I think
they become a little bit more mature and
wiser so that the money becomes a little
bit more like valued and not wasted on
some of those girls who just want to
well there's a famous quote I think when
it comes to money from my experience in
my debt business that men are more
prudent with the financial resources
than women are right but don't you think
women also can be a little bit more
persuasive for men to spend that money
oh women are very good at extracting
reasons let's be honest yeah yeah the
the what's the famous quote regarding
money uh is that a man with money meets
a man with experience the man with the
money walks away with an experience the
man with experience walks away with the
money the lesson there you go right
there by the way can I borrow 20 bucks
from you real quick yeah let me just
yeah that never happens okay I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find bunch of useful links to my website
my supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out